okay so the boys episode a closes out
season three in a way that will melt
your brain the new finale is filled with
easter eggs comic callbacks and some
major moments that you know we have to
talk about what i love about this season
is that it ends much like how it began
and in episode 1 we got some amazing
foreshadowing to the final few scenes we
of course opened the season with the
dawn of the seven movie and in that we
saw wartower and flames with a toppled
statue of soulja boy in front of it come
the close of episode 8 you also get this
exact same thing happening with board
tower slightly destroyed and the soldier
boy statue toppled over it's sort of
like poetry a rhyme and it brings
everything together really well from the
first episode of the season up to the
last now the first major question you'll
likely have is what's gonna happen to
ryan well he's not a character in the
comics so knows however for years it's
been theorized that he's gonna turn into
soulja boy this is because earlier in
the series he's batted off several of
the states in america this is something
soldier boy also did in the comics and
because of this a lot of people thought
it was foreshadowing his eventual
turn-in team however when jensen ackles
was cast as the character many brushed
it to the side as being something that
was wrong but i think there might
actually be some truth to it now in the
comics there were three versions of
soulja boy with the first one being a
world war two hero much like what we
have here the third one also took a big
focus in the source material and it is
possible that ryan will end up taking
his grandfather's mantle at some point
in the future now we start with ryan at
grace's home and he's actually wearing
the colours of soulja boy in the comics
namely blue white and red he's throwing
fastballs against the earth symbolizing
that there's no father figure in his
life to play catch with baseball is
homeland his favorite sport and if we
jump back to episode 6 and season 1 we
also had a similar scene to this
homelander threw a fastball off into the
sky and this is of course murder and
ryan here turns out that victoria did
give him this location last week and
this is such a tense scene to start off
the episode with at the end of the entry
we have it revealed that grace survived
this encounter and she oversees soldier
boy being put into containment guessing
this means that he belongs to the cia
now and they might attempt to study him
in order to find a way to destroy the
compound being the supes lots of
theories that we're going to be breaking
down but if you enjoy the video then i
hope you hit the thumbs up button one
last time and make sure you subscribe as
we've still got a lot of boys content
coming up over the next couple of weeks
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the boys season
3 finale now ryan holds himself a
cannibal for the death of becca and he
thinks his father's mad at him because
she passed away however he reassures him
that accidents happen and that he'll
always be there for him cote d'ivoire
tower where we see a protest playing out
lots of similarities to the turbo rush
ad and they have both pro homelander and
pro starlight fans going off at each
other it's obviously a left versus right
metaphor i'll i'll be honest it's not
that subtle and the starlight stands
have signs at play and we can do it
believe starlight hashtag me too playing
unbelievable women follow the light and
fight like a girl homeland aside has
snowflakes written on a couple of things
god's guns in homeland up and keep
america safe there's also a swastika
there and a confederate flag so
you kind of get the idea what's going on
with homelanders fans now they also
started by chan saying starlight lied
children died which as we've mentioned
in other videos is a play on the old
insert politician name comma people died
this hashtag also popped up during the
live stream at the end of episode 6 when
starlight was revealing the truth
starlight side have come to get made out
of vote and we learn that the attorney
general is coming with a warrant so that
he can search the premises ashley and
the dp are over here in the white cell
which mirrors the scene in which
vogelbaum and another scientist looked
over a young homelander this is shown in
the recap section for the episode making
me think it's done for that reason but
that might be a reach
now maeve is knocked out using another
chuck a poison that becomes important
later on and when we see her being
escorted by a swat team she's wearing
the same mask that soulja boy later has
she wakes up out of this possibly
hinting that soulja boy might end up
being brought back for the fourth season
ackles absolutely killed it as the
character and with him surviving the
episode i'd love to see him return now
we discover that frenchie has placed
another chuck into a starlight perfume
bottle and this is ties to the salisbury
poisoning that happened in march 2018
russian agents ended up placing the
poison inside a perfume bottle that they
attempted to use on a former russian
agent and also his daughter after its
use the capsule was dispensed of but
unfortunately it was found by the
boyfriend of dawn sturgis who then gave
it to her as a gift she ended up using
it and unfortunately she died from the
nerve agent whilst the other two
russians survived this idea of poisoning
is reflected in huey whose ear is
bleeding green b24 like fluid hinting at
the danger to it at mother's milk mm
wears a snoop dogg t-shirt again
mirroring all the hip-hop ones that he's
worn throughout the show after hitting
todd last week he feels like he let
jeanine down he'll now have the image of
him smacking the character burned into
her mind todd ends up getting further
integrated into becoming a homelander
supporter and come the end of the season
he cheers on him murdering a starlight
follower both jeanine and ryan witnessed
their dads committing acts of violence
whilst todd was there which i'm sure was
done on purpose now rather than vnn
reporting the stream we see this as nnc
a cnn parody who gave a different take
in spin than the propaganda cameron
coleman would though things are looking
bad for homelander due to her filming
him last week black noir returns to give
somewhat of a morale boost he's got the
cartoon animals with him once more which
eric kripke talked about with tv line
earlier in the week the showrunner said
he wanted this to mimic snow white in
the scene in which the forest comes
alive around here with all the animals
following her through it black noir of
course also means black black and snow
white is an opposite to this with them
both being things that are white great
easter eggs in the video as always now
jude noir being unable to talk they said
they had to create a way to explain the
character's backstory and doing this all
in his head was the best way to go about
it he arrives just as ashley in the deep
dropped the bad news about maeve and he
genuinely wants to work with homelander
to help kill soulja boy the bad news is
that homie now knows he's his father and
he's furious that noir kept it from him
sadly the man who does nothing but
hilarious physical comedy gets his guts
ripped out by homelander and he dies
never getting to be the next eddie
murphy hilarious scene in the build up
to it though with noir writing notes out
and this is the biggest deviation from
the comics in the show the comics had
him being revealed as a clone of
homelander who drove him insane because
he wanted to kill him noir's entire
reason for being was to take homeland
down in case he went rogue and thus he
drove him crazy by dressing up as him
and killing countless people however in
the series homelander has x-ray vision
so he'd instantly know if he was a clone
so they changed it up to this arc with a
sympathetic character ervin big big
death to have him go out this early and
with him being killed it makes you
wonder who they're going to use to
finally take home lander out he's
becoming nigh and unstoppable and i'll
talk more in just a bit about who i
think's going to take him on but noir
being firmly off the board definitely
whittles down the choices now we jump to
a gas station and we see a train
cigarettes outside as well as brave made
lollies when we cut indoors billy then
ends up knocking huey out after he says
he's the spitting image of his brother
this is of course due to the guilt he
carries and how he feels responsible for
lenny's death we then join aetrane and
his brother in what i actually think is
one of the best scenes in the episode
it's a testament to the boy's writing
that even minor stories like this get a
major payoff with nathan being angered
that blue hawk didn't get true justice
he brings up a trains of menthol vapes
further playing on the evolution of the
cigarette ad from before showing how
both he and vaught are always looking
for opportunities to make money his
brother feels like he's once more just
doing things with complete disregard for
his family in home even though it's
pretty clear that the character has
changed a train can also obviously now
run again and though he's on a walking
stick he will recover or as nate will be
stuck in a wheelchair now the fall of
this relationship is juxtaposed how's
that word again by annie and huey
repairing theirs the bear have a car
ride together which is of course
something that they've done throughout
the series to have heart to heart huey
talks about his father who's played by
simon pegg and peg was who hughey was
based on in the comics and though he was
originally supposed to play the lead
time got the better of him and he aged
up out of it used that easter egg before
but that's just for the people who don't
watch me every week which if you don't
go yourself now huey talks about how he
thought his father not fighting for his
mother was weakness but it was actually
strength because he stayed with his son
to make sure he was safe this is
reflected in annie who just wants what's
best for huey and she's always been
there for him even when he's been proven
wrong time and time again this idea of
support is murdering kimiko and frenchie
a ladder of which is anger that he's
basically just an attack dog for cruel
people he talks about his father's abuse
but in issue 39 when we met him he it
was a nice blow now we don't actually
find out what happened to nina and it is
possible she'll return next season as
one of the minor villains in the comics
she operated in russia and gathered
together several supes in order to throw
a coup with vort supplying the army nina
had been given a special form of v that
she could trigger and make people's
heads explode and she was going to send
the army in let them overthrow the
russian government kill them all and
make it seem like she just saved the day
however this was a double cross by
vaught who just wanted her to take the
fall and this could possibly be adapted
into a season 4 story with her still
being alive jump over to the flat iron
building which also doubles as the boys
headquarters in the comics soldier boy
and butcher talk about fatherly
relationships an ongoing theme
throughout the series in pretty much
every instance of this the father and
child relationship is destroyed and this
is actually really important to bear in
mind for how the ending flips it on its
head victoria ended up screwing over her
father figure in stan edgar billy of
course hated his dad homelander and
soldier boy have duked it out at several
points and janine and mm on exactly on
the best of terms after he hit todd like
you should hit that like button now come
the end of the entry though homelander
and ryan are closer than they've ever
been this is because ryan follows his
father down the dark path is on razzie
other characters didn't homelander even
turn against his oldest friend black
noir in order to keep his dad safe
soldier boy then brings up the soldier
boys story and how it lost best picture
to an american in paris dating the movie
as being from 1951 he then spouts off
how it's all bs and he mentions a
captain america-esque origin story about
how a kid with a heart of gold
discovered he had incredible abilities
in steve's story he was injected with
super soldier serum but what made it
seem like soulja boy got his powers
naturally because they didn't want the
public learning the truth about compound
v this was also seen in homelander who
had an entire fake origin story designed
for him that was supposed to be similar
to the form that clark kent had the
truth is that soldier boys died on
several steel mills and he sent him off
to boarding school he was expelled from
several and his father rather than being
physically abusive to him he belittled
him and said he wasn't good enough to
carry his name he then went to his dad's
friends in the war department and ended
up becoming the strongest man alive
however his father said he took a
shortcut showing why soldier boy is the
way he is i love the theme of fathers
throughout the series and it's going to
be interesting to see how it's brought
in orion and as ark next week now that
takes us in the theater time every time
every time so soldier boy is put on ice
at the end of the episode and though he
seems like he could be brought back i
actually think it might be ryan who
takes down homelander again this series
is all about dads and their kids with
pretty much all the children turning
against their father figures at some
point even huey did by the signs of his
childhood and therefore we have this
constantly repeating theme i think this
is all setting up that will have a big
focus on ryan turning against his father
and he of course has both billy and
grace who've been pushed out of his life
i think the series will culminate with
him making a choice between turning into
his father and cementing the supes
ruling the world or standing against
them due to how everything is left at
the end with a seven being all but
destroyed i can imagine that if
homelander is taken out that vault will
go with them too they of course removed
stan edgar homelander is now in charge
and ashley isn't exactly stable so i
think it's all going to come down to
ryan versus homelander and that will be
how the show closes out probably wrong
like i've been wrong about most of the
other theories but that's in it every
time
gonna be about two years till the next
series so you'll not remember this
anyway so just pretend i'm right you
know got it all right every time
now after ambushing butcher frenchie
says no for once and huey says that he
thinks billy wants him to be his canary
once more and pull him back like lenny
would maeve maeves are made miss maeve
sorry maeve makes a grave mistake and
she throws out the poison and sides with
billy though they're initially locked up
they escape and work together to win and
this idea of separation causing
someone's downfall is shown on the
opposite side when we travel to vort
omanda reveals that noir is dead because
he kept secrets from him and he also
touches upon his first press conference
this was shown to us in the boy's
diabolical and it was also the first
time that noir and homeland worked
together mirroring how this ended up
being the last now he asks the deep to
kill a vice president front runner who
we see in the next scene swimming in his
home deep initially says that's treason
but he still carries out the job and at
the end of the episode we learned this
was put in place to allow victoria to
become the vp after he appeared in the
news report last week i kind of had a
feeling they'd do this and that's one
theory at least right for the whole
season we got one right we're officially
the best now in the comics vic the veep
ended up killing the president and he
took the number one spot which led to
vaude controlling all of america every
law was changed to allow them to do
whatever they wanted and the supes were
given more legal powers i can see this
being what happens in the next season
and victoria might even be the reason
why homelander doesn't end up getting
turned into a criminal for killing the
protester at the end i definitely think
she's going to be the president and in
the comics homelander ended up ripping
off fick's head which would be ironic if
he did it in the series because she
blows heads like ryan aries mom
he also tells ashy to take off her wig
revealing that she's almost pulled all
her hair out to the point of complete
baldness i think this is fully lining
her up now as being the shell
counterpart of jessica from the comics
who ripped her own hair out towards the
end of the run homelander watches some
of the world war ii propaganda featuring
soulja boy and not only did he come from
him but he also got his catchphrase from
him too oh
and uh captain
who's the real hero real heroes real
heroes
you guys you guys you guys
[Applause]
now as butcher enters we see a poster
for vorton friends which is a play on
fox and friends this room is filled with
news anchor parodies and the final fight
itself takes place in the vort news
network room homelander then reveals
that he killed noir which was soldier
boy's main goal soldier boy has of
course talked about how he always wanted
kids throughout the season but here he
finally shuts down the idea by turning
on his own son he also utters the same
thing his father said to him which is
that he is a disappointment ryan ends up
saving his father as they restrain him
and once soldier boy strikes back it
sets billy off to stop him from wiping
them both out before he can superman
that whole line there now obviously the
idea of fathers comes up again and next
season i think we'll see billion
homelander duking it out for ryan's
future he of course made a promise to
becca and knowing that he's living on
borrowed time means that he might end up
trying to kill homeland so that ryan
isn't left in his care i can see ryan
going back to grace after the death of
billy and this would also make up for
her losing her grandchildren to
lamplighter we get this big fight
between billion soldier boy whilst maven
homeland that go head-to-head the latter
is a big one in the comics and due to
the ending of the episode i think that
it's as close as we'll get to that in
the source material the pair fought it
out with maeve busting out his sword it
was revealed that she'd planted bugs
throughout fort tower so that the boys
could spy on the seven and this was
testament to treason as starlight
attempted to escape maven homey duked it
out with the ladder ripping her head off
and throwing it out the building i
genuinely thought that they were doing
something along those lines when she
died at the tower so good on the boys
for tricking me but i spoiled the whole
show so back at you you chump see ya
chump
anyway she ends up getting stabbed in
the eye and this is of course meant to
mirror stormfront getting the same thing
done to her last season homelander also
does some of the things he did to
stormfront 2 including lasering her
tits don't be a [ __ ] laser my [ __ ]
tits now he also went out with both
stormfront and maeve and is clearly just
obsessed with making her go through the
same things that she did huey gets
everyone to evacuate the building and
ashley rejects other ashley from joining
her as they travel to the roof this
reminded me a lot of red skull in the
first captain america movie and it also
shows how little ashley cares about the
staff kimiko ends up playing maniac by
michael cembello and she dances similar
to alex in flash dance you might
remember that she got the idea for this
last week when she was sitting with
starlight at mother milk's house and
they watched the music video for it it
all leads to a big fight in the main
room with stala absorbing all the energy
from the light bulbs after huey adds to
the energy crisis in the flat iron when
she was locked up they ended up turning
out all the lights as her power comes
purely from this nice little focus on
her shoes too which we can also see a
white with a star on him mort don't miss
a trick baby a homelander also gets
stabbed in the air perhaps meaning that
he ends up deaf in it for the next entry
his super hearing has been a big talking
point in the season so they could be
setting up ways for the boys to work
around him though
though he would have have the other ear
now moving on i may have ends up diving
out with soulja boy and butcher actually
protects ryan though it leads to him
going off with his dad however this
feeling of the two being separated and
butcher fighting for him whilst homeland
the left has to stand for something
billy ends up collapsing and he's given
12 to 18 months to live because of
compound v24 i want to talk about what i
think will happen at the end of the
video as it's a big big comic spoiler
bigger than the other ones but yeah a
devastating scene mother's milk also
explains to his daughter his family's
past and the truth about superheroes
however he spins it to talk about her
grandfather being a force for good who
fought to get justice you might also
notice that mm's finger is tapping on
the picture here as he explained to
starlight earlier in the season this was
ocd he developed after the murders
carried out by soulja boy this called
all the way back to the second season in
which he also did it in the car during
the road trip however jeanine reaches
out and stops his finger finally showing
that it's okay we then see soldier boy
has been quote unquote put to rest and
vauda running memorial reports for queen
maeve it's crazy to think super sonic
black noir and maeve are now all out the
seven but at least she gets a happy
ending as she's reunited with elena when
we last saw her she said she needed some
time for herself after seeing that plain
footage but it's nice that maeve
actually got to be back with her when
she went to belly she made it clear she
wanted to be normal and she also brings
up their first meeting in the bathroom
this was something that also happened in
the comics and it put the pieces in
place for maeve to eventually sacrifice
herself to buy starlight time ashley and
annika end up deleting the footage of
her being rescued showing that the
she-e-o is intent on protecting her
whereas once she was happy to lock her
up they're also happy to run the idea
that maeve is dead and we later see a
billboard outside the flat iron with
remembering maverick on it over the top
of this we hear the song goodbye yellow
brick road by ellen john this song is
about going back to one's roots but here
it's very much about going back to
basics soldier boy is put back in stasis
the deep is back on his own with his
reputation as being sexually abusive
fully restored
here we go again this is because
cassandra has released a book called
into deep my journey to freedom which is
about her escaping the relationship this
pr move is of course similar to the one
deep dead with him saying that he left
the church the quote along the top of
the book is by stephanie
cortrumer ko
trumps
an art director who also worked on
pacific rim
what an
idiot now deeb is back under the control
of homelander and this is seen by a
picture of him and the character
overlooking his bed at the boy's hq and
he dumps her costume and she ends up
joining the boys big change up from the
comics and above the shoot we can see
some black and white photos of the soups
mirroring how they were presented in the
comics mother's milk wears a two pack
t-shirt and it's all eyes on v
like victoria newman with the news
report about her getting the vp this is
on nnc and if you look at the banner
along the bottom you can see how this is
reporting mainly for the left with both
ted cruz and ron desantis making up the
headlines the latter says that he's
banning woke starlight teachers from
florida playing on recent controversies
involving the state in school with
little time left butcher announces that
victoria has to go and we end outside
for tower we can see some storm chasers
carrying the s symbol she had which was
based on the ss logo from the second
world war there's also a character
wearing horns and the stars and stripes
face paint which is of course playing on
jacob chansley who was splashed all over
the news after the capitol building
incident in 2021 the redhead from the
first rally spots homelander and at this
point ryan flies in gonna be honest with
you mate my brain's got about about 200
tv shows comics and movies stored in it
so i might have misremembered this but
but i think yeah i think this might be
the first time that we see ryan fly he
was of course pushed off the roof early
in the series by his dad and this shows
how he's grown in power homelander kills
a protester but rather than being
condemned he's cheered on now no longer
having to hide who he is we end with
ryan smiling reminding me a lot of the
ending of the omen perhaps ushering in
the spawn of satan well well superman
himself now that ends the boys and what
a season it was it's crazy that this is
now three seasons deep and it's still
knocking it out the park the finale was
incredible and i think the season has
been consistently brilliant can't wait
to see where they go from here and
that's the perfect way to end a season
wondering what's coming next as for that
well they've now given belly a reason to
up the ante like your uncle due to the
ticking time bomb that's now on his head
guys living on borrowed time and major
comic spoilers for his eventual arc
still here thanks so butcher ends up
deciding that no one on earth should
have compound b this is something that
he brought up in the meeting with maeve
and i think it was put in place to
clearly hinted them following this arc
butcher ended up murdering all the boys
love sausage and grace before he set his
sights on using the exploding v to kill
supes across the world however he
subconsciously set things in place so
that huey could pull him back from the
brink and finally stop him this led to
the two facing off against each other
with huey coming out on top as they fell
off a higher level of the empire state
building butcher was badly injured and
he died happy that he'd failed could
definitely see this being something they
end up doing and with season four due to
start filming in august i can't wait
until we get more information on it i
think that from soulja boy billy will
find a way to destroy compound b
completely and that will be his final
final mission now there is a way he can
survive this and starlight of course
stole several vials of compound v last
week to give to kimiko there's still a
lot left but i kind of think billy
taking it would go against his
principles anyway that's your lot don't
be a
and write something nice in the comments
as a thank you you'll get entered into a
competition where we're giving away
three copies of everything everywhere
all at once on the 15th of july all you
have to do to be with the chance of
winning is like i said make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode we picked the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one on screen right now so if
that's you message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of thor which will be
linked on screen right now fun movie go
check it out if you want to learn about
that post credit scene and also just get
some spoilers for it hopefully i see you
over there and enjoy the rest weekend
mate thanks for all the support and for
riding with me take care peace